halsey is a mom i am very happy yes i
am the 26 year old singer gave birth to
her first child with aylev aiden
halsey first announced she was pregnant
in january sharing these stunning
maternity photos to instagram
she captioned the pics simply surprise
and aylev wrote in the comments
heart so full i love you sweetness to
which the mom to be replied
i love you and i love this mini human
[Music]
already
to multiple reports at the time halsey
and the 37 year old screenwriter
had been dating for several months and
they knew each other for a while before
a romance blossomed
and just last month we got a little more
backstory to their relationship a
twitter user shared an article from 2018
which announced the development of a
movie loosely based on halsey's life
with the pop star set to play the title
role the fan wrote
why did this never happen well halsey
stepped in with the answer and tweeted
back because aylev was supposed to be
writing it the past three years
and we slowly fell in love instead you
know the rest
and this happy news is all the more
joyous considering halsey's journey with
endometriosis
which can cause infertility when i
finally got my endometriosis diagnosis
was with dr aliabadi she took one look
at me and i explained her
my symptoms and she said you have
endometriosis and it was so bittersweet
because it was like the relief
of knowing i wasn't making it all up and
i wasn't being sensitive
and it wasn't all in my head halsey
opened up about her struggles in this
2018 appearance on the doctors
she went on to reveal that she had also
endured a pregnancy loss
i was on tour i found out i was pregnant
and before i could even really
figure out what that meant to me and
what that meant for my future
for my career for my life my
relationship
the next thing i knew i was on stage
miscarrying
um in the middle of my concert in 2017
halsey underwent surgery for her
endometriosis
and days after announcing her pregnancy
in january she shared this photo to her
instagram stories
halsey drew two arrows pointing to the
scars she received from the procedure
and she wrote on the photo the scars
that got me this angel
hashtag endo warrior i remind myself
that you know
if i'm doing well and the people i love
are happy and taken care of then
everything is good over the years halsey
has also been very vocal about how much
it would mean for her to become a mother
in 2016 she told rolling stone magazine
i want to be a mom more than i want to
be a pop star
more than i want to be anything in the
world that being said halsey is one mama
who can do both
[Music]
on top of announcing her pregnancy in
january halsey officially canceled her
long postponed
manic world tour citing health and
safety concerns amid the coronavirus
pandemic
but to clear up any speculation that her
pregnancy influenced the cancellation
halsey tweeted this gem and just so
we're aware if it wasn't for kovid
i would have done the tour pregnant
you